well let's head back to that breaking
news now the historic deal brokered by
the u.s to normalize relations between
the uae and israel harry fawcett is live
for us now
in west jerusalem harry how major a
development is this
uh it's a huge development this is
something that benjamin netanyahu has
been
talking about and working towards for
much of his political career the idea of
normalizing relations
between israel and its important uh
arab muslim neighbors in the region and
this is the first such
agreement in full he has been working uh
on various
levels uh trying to to get better ties
and has
celebrated various minor victories in
terms of minor improvements
with various neighbors but this
according to the joint statement
released by the united states by israel
and by the uae
amounts to a full normalization and a
development of
full ties between the two countries the
statement says that
the delegations from both countries will
meet in the coming weeks
to sign these agreements that there will
be uh normalization of diplomatic ties
of
economic medical technological
telecommunications cooperation
direct flights between israel and the
uae tourist flights
as well as business flights and
importantly it also says that as a
result
of what this statement calls a historic
breakthrough
uh israel will suspend its efforts to
annex parts of the occupied west bank
the parts
of the west bank that were designated to
be israeli territory
under the trump jared kushner peace plan
which had created such a great deal of
heat and noise
in recent months with benjamin
netanyahu's vow to just move ahead
with u.s support and start annexing well
ahead of any
potential agreement with the
palestinians now that is
suspended in its entirety and instead
the statement says israel will work on
expanding its relations with other
muslim arab countries in the region um
i haven't seen any reaction yet from the
palestinian side from
allah but i think the reaction would be
that israel appears to be being rewarded
for not doing something
rather than having any real progress in
terms of the
the peace process between uh israel and
the palestinians
of course under the arab peace
initiative there should come
first a settlement to the
israeli-palestinian conflict before
any normalization so this is uh is a
major upset in terms of
what had been the uh the sort of
explicit thinking and policy
of arab states up until this point think
of that we'll leave it there for now
uh harry fawcett live for us from west
jerusalem alan fisher
joins us now live uh from washington d.c
for u.s
reaction alan i mean this was brokered
by the us this is going to be seen as a
huge win for donald trump
well certainly it came from donald trump
just in the oval office not far from
where i'm standing just a few minutes
ago he was surrounded
by his senior advisers we'll get the
tape of that announcement
very shortly probably within the next
few minutes he said that the
announcement had been made that the
united arab emirates and israel were
normalizing relations that they were
going to sign
some sort of treaty and that other arab
countries
would follow he said there are things
happening that he couldn't talk about
at this point now clearly this is
something that
will please the trump administration it
is a big
foreign policy win as harry was saying
there has been
the kushner peace plan for the middle
east which has stalled going absolutely
nowhere
that was revealed several months ago and
has absolutely
done nothing since that point and so
there'll be questions though
about why the united arab emirates and
israel if there was something as
significant
and as fundamental as a peace deal to be
announced between
these two countries why the leaders
themselves
wouldn't announce it why they would
allow donald trump to do that from the
oval office
is this perhaps a sign that both
countries would like to aid donald
trump's re-election effort
in some way we know that israel are very
close
is very close to donald trump they
believe that he has been a huge
supporter
during his time in the oval office from
moving
the embassy to jerusalem to recognizing
israeli sovereignty over the occupied
golan heights
there was some concern too that the
white house would give the go-ahead to
allow
israel to annex parts of the west bank
although that
was stopped it ran into the mud over the
last few weeks or so
and we know that the united arab
emirates enjoy a good relationship
uh with donald trump as does saudi
arabia and so
there will be political questions about
this but certainly as far as donald
trump and the white house is concerned
this is a major diplomatic victory and
uh alan as you sort of mentioned there
the u.s
had recently sort of taken the foot off
the gas in terms of their support
for those annexation plans hadn't they
had this been sort of
uh you know were there signs that this
might be on the way
well there was no indication in fact i i
got a phone call
probably about five ten minutes before
the announcement was made to tell me
there was a big announcement coming and
it involved israel and the united arab
emirates
i then started making several calls
myself to try and establish it
and then we heard that donald trump was
making the announcement
in the oval office himself uh
it's an interesting state of affairs
because we know that donald trump tried
to get a peace deal with north korea
that's essentially lying in tatters at
the moment we know that they've
exercised
the the campaign of maximum pressure on
iran to try and bring them
to the negotiating table that had failed
and we saw the failure of that
personified in the fact
that brian hooke who is the main
negotiator the point man on
all talks with iran left his post
just the other week and we know that
kellyanne conway stood on the driveway
that you see behind me
in the white house saying that she
expected an announcement from the
president
about annexation and we thought that
that meant he was going to give the okay
for that and that was several weeks ago
and then nothing happened there were
technical points to be discussed
so whether or not the whole discussion
between israel and the united arab
emirates
gained momentum at that point i think
will become clear when people start to
write their books about this moment in
history
but clearly the the trump white house
was looking
for a foreign policy victory because
they've had precious few
of them up to this point and so to be
able to sit down
in the oval office and as the president
of the united states announced
that there was going to be a peace deal
between the uae and
israel unusual though that is it
certainly signifies a big win for donald
trump and something that he needed given
that
the past 48 hours has been dominated by
joe biden and his pick for vice
president
thank you so much for that ellen fischer
there live in washington d.c